welcome to this video interested
tortures me higher Clint Walker okay you
sound kind of i get a king's in here
probably just by transposition yeah the
age three lines and they don't know them
that well this is an interesting way to
play it a bit offbeat but not so bad and
transposing into the fianchetto lines
okay so there is some pressure on your
form I don't know what this is certainly
a theoretical position would be very
weird if not but I'm not really knowing
that I don't think he can take you for d
for hangs but yeah so what now f3 yaar
it's a bit much pressure there may be a
doesn't don't think that's so bad it
looks a bit uh pneumonias but if I
getting route 81 Bishop f2 and so on
it's it's totally fine
Queen 85 okay maybe is going for some
counter play there I don't know takes e4
bishop f1 traps and queen so we cannot
take and to this Knight b6 Bishop
everyone and it's fairly save them
one thing that is not going away said we
q6 bond let's see snide f3 993 gives
away e4 that's not not a good idea maybe
I can just let looks a bit strange
moving the night away
yeah maybe still do that ask him about
that 26 porn
so is counter-attacking uh-huh yeah I
can move the night though simply simply
keeping this simply protecting this even
back to be one I don't know how good
that is but it is a possibility just
root g 6 i'm not sure about maybe i'm
just wrote these six and then e five
this is very often not a bad decision ok
i'm doing this but i'm not quite sure
not quite sure because e 5 will cut off
and cut off his bishop down just feel
that my pieces are not super ammonius at
the moment that could could be better
the piece coordination ok what about
this if I can wait I can take their I'd
have 94 will be five let's that's
clarify the situation and 94 I asked
where Queen B 5 is actually quite ok
what do I have 94 actually 94 queen bee
tool and I couldn't be towards a trade
unfortunately it's a trade so it's not
working
okay f2 then if you Teague's we would
have the series of trades okay have to
be a bit cautious with the time
I'm threatening 94 though so I think he
had to do this ok so i guess on the
default cannot be so bad and now create
this a for hanging not sure if he can
afford it
whoa really check I don't believe it
Queen f7 Queen f7 rook f8 just barely
holes and if I take and then Queen f7
I'll see you covering both queen d 8 is
not on I don't see it let's take and how
is he covering the rook and the bishop
black resides yeah he isn't okay well
tough game tough game this is a fairly
normal looking position for this opening
but i'm not an expert as I said yeah
yeah if Knight f3 is right but very
often it is a good thing to trade d6
against you for that much I know and
went here here now we five yeah for
cutting off that Bishop that is 11 key
IDM and went there and now I took on c5
I don't know maybe that isn't a good
decision I don't know Group D D 1 is
given by the comp now keeping more
pieces on the board maybe yeah here I
thought I maybe have a slight edge queen
bee three is given by the engine also
the slide edge I thought about this size
but I thought that 94 he would win a
porn isn't it nah f6 is interesting this
is the comp line
and I black has some compensation never
see five splits play all this and the
engine gives Ruby am and I had the
suspicion actually that this might work
the thing is if I check it and grab here
yes Queen d3 and I felt that this might
be enough kingi to this Queenie to him
Black is in fact in good shape Ian yeah
so I after group d 8 had to plate it
would have had to play something since I
and here that I'm just winning f6 is not
not a playroom yeah yeah there was a
sudden end to that game which was very
complicated unclear per team essentially
blundered this year with f6 okay well
thanks for watching